[Musique]
vettier le beaucoup de monde hier soir
pour regarder les annonces du chef de
l'état à la télé énormément mon 35 8
millions de téléspectateurs
après plusieurs jours de suspense la
france et reconfirmer plus de différence
entre les départements c'est un effort
qui nous faut faire dans ce moment voilà
qui est un moment charnière dans la
lutte contre les lobbys on va de pièces
quant au fiasco
le sentiment qu'on a on écouterait
modèle macron c'est finalement qu'est ce
qui a été réussi depuis un an depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire
hier j'ai eu l'impression d'assister à
un poisson d'avril quand j'entendais le
président la république qui venait nous
dire que ben il y allait y avoir des
créations de deux lits en réanimation
les hôpitaux ça fait un an que les
soignants demande avec tout ce que nous
avons fait le l'élève français au monde
sera l'un de ceux qui aura eu l'année
scolaire 2020 21 la moins anormales
possible la plus continuer si possible
sans décrochages
on nous dit aujourd'hui avec un argument
que je récuse on a gagné du temps non on
a perdu du temps on a perdu des vies des
vies chaque jour où le nombre de morts
c'est l'équivalent d'un airbus qui
s'écrase nous en souffrons toutes et
tous et nous allons encore en souffrir
toutes et tous dans un confinement qui
devrait être plus long que s'il n'avait
été un confinement par anticipation
donc on a raté le moment où on pouvait
confiné durement et cassé et en gros ce
que je vous dis c'est pas une blague
on a en gros quatre cents morts par jour
peut-être plus si on compte les
hélicoptères fait il faut manger et on
s'en fout complètement
ça me sidère par le président de la
république me dis ce soir nous avons
gagné des jours de liberté c'est faux
nous avons simplement perdu du temps du
fait de ces décisions hasardeuses et à
aucun moment il ya le moindre je mens
pas un mea culpa je demande pas qui se
met à genoux devant les français mais il
déroule toujours le même discours mais
qui peut le croire je pense qu emmanuel
macron
devra rendre des comptes sur la manière
dont cette épidémie elle a été gérée
je pense que l'union européenne devra
rendre des comptes parce qu'on est
aujourd'hui la risée du monde
et c'est vrai quand on le premier
ministre être très fier de son bilan
comme l'était hier soir le président de
la république sans faire aucun mea culpa
nous raconter n'importe quoi sur les
vaccins et bien c'est évidemment
affligeant et c'est la raison pour
laquelle effectivement prêts ministre a
été chahuté nous avons là une plaie nous
avons choisi la voie d'une possible
sortie de crise oui c'est un mauvais
poisson d'avril est le poisson d'avril
comme tous les poisson pourrit par la
tête
les français par contre n'ont pas une
mémoire de poisson rouge eux le premier
ministre très remonté lui aussi contre
ces groupes d'opposition parlementaire
qui ont décidé unanimement de boycotter
le vote sur les nouvelles mesures
sanitaires de son gouvernement
une défiance des communistes jusqu'aux
bancs de la droite
votre stratégie de vaccination ce n'est
plus un pari perdu
c'est une bérézina sanitaires elle était
la musique de ses interventions les
commerces les fermes et pauvres
les stations de ski ne les ferme et pas
les universités ouvrent élèves les
établissements publics culturels ont
vraiment
et ces jeunes j'ai entendu ça depuis des
semaines pour ne pas parler des
discothèques et aujourd'hui voilà une
internaute annonce un dans le sud on est
complet on a plus de paix qu il va
pleuvoir ce week end n'y pensez même pas
nous ne sommes pas là dans un an sort de
théâtre où jean castex ce matin avec sa
colère simuler et un très mauvais
acteurs de ce théâtre cette année
propose à l'internaute demandez à vos
enfants de chercher les oeufs de pâques
alors que vous n'en avez pas acheter ça
les habituera pour quand ils voudront se
faire vacciner c'est long